when you hear the title bride of chucky
the first thing you're probably going to
think of is bride of frankenstein the
1935 sequel to frankenstein starring
boris karloff that's the movie we see
tiffany watching in the bathtub early on
in bride of chucky she's alive if you
haven't seen it there are some
similarities primarily the main message
of frankenstein and bride of
frankenstein which is actually just told
to us a verbatim in the movie there's a
character for mary shelley the author of
the frankenstein novel and she explains
the moral of the story before we jump
into it
the punishment that befell a mortal man
who dared to emulate god bride of chucky
explores similar territory although it
has no opening where don mancini just
straight up tells the audience what the
movie is about it tells the story of
tiffany valentine who collects the
pieces of the chucky doll and stitches
them back together to try to bring back
her ex-boyfriend charles lee ray but
ends up regretting it when she's treated
poorly by him i'm going to talk about
the more specific homages that bride of
chucky paves to bride of frankenstein
but there is another horror movie that
ironically probably influenced bride of
chucky way more to learn the
significance of tiffany's nail file
stick around to the end of this video
[Music]
welcome to things you missed back in
2019 i made a series of videos on the
child's play movies the first three
movies in the chucky franchise so if you
want to watch those you can check out to
this playlist and if you're already
watching that playlist now you know why
i'm suddenly significantly less awkward
bride of chucky is a sequel to child's
play 3 taking place no more than a
couple of months after it would be the
first movie not to feature series
protagonist annie barkley because they
screwed themselves in the third one by
recasting andy with an older actor and
now that actor is too old to play andy
because the movie is set while he's
still a teen i mean they could go back
to the original andy who is now the
perfect age but then it would clearly be
two different people i think a lot of
people probably just wanted to see brad
doroth back as chucky though and they
would have gotten their wish let's get
in to the things you missed
[Music]
both bride of frankenstein and bride of
chucky the revivals are triggered by
electricity the voodoo spell used to
bring back chucky involves a
supernatural storm cloud issuing a
strike of lightning then chucky kills
tiffany by electrocuting her in the bath
and uses the spell to transfer her soul
into another doll this time chucky is
stitched together by hand after tiffany
retrieved the pieces that were torn
apart in the giant spinning fan at the
end of child's play 3. this gives him a
similar look to frankenstein's monster
who is famously stitched together by his
creator in both movies the titular
couples don't end up getting along
[Music]
friend
but as i mentioned i don't think bride
of frankenstein was the biggest
inspiration for the fourth chucky movie
if you look at some of the marketing it
becomes very clear that universal
pictures was trying to capitalize on the
success of a more recent franchise as
the official poster is a direct parody
of scream 2 and the logo with its point
decay is basically a ripoff of the
stream logo stream took the horror world
by storm in 1996 thanks in part to its
horror genre satire and abundant
self-awareness stream is basically a
slasher movie that knows it's a slasher
movie and stream 2 satirizes the cliches
of horror movie sequels the opening
scene of scream references many horror
movies that came before it in the iconic
do you like scary movies dialogue which
includes references to halloween
nightmare on elm street and friday the
13th the opening scene of bride of
chucky does a very similar thing we look
inside the evidence room at the lockport
police department where we see michael
meyer's mask from halloween freddy
krueger's glove from nightmare on elm
street and jason's mask from friday the
13th this may also be leatherface's
chainsaw from the texas chainsaw
massacre a cop gathers up the remains of
chucky and brings them to tiffany who
takes him out with her sharp nail file
which has this curved tip that makes it
look like the knife used by ghostface in
the scream movies additionally there's a
moment during that opening scene of
scream where the killer refers to casey
as blondie can you handle that
blondie
chucky's bride ends up being a blonde
woman whose soul gets transferred into a
black-haired doll so she bleaches the
hair back to blonde while listening to
blondie the name of the blondie song is
call me the killer in scream intimidates
victims by calling them on the phone and
tiffany hires her neighbor to transport
the dolls and bride by calling him on
the phone so that he doesn't find out
that she's one of the dolls shout out to
this guy for getting a couple horror
movies into the top comments on the
music video for call me as i mentioned
stream's biggest gimmick is that it's
very self-aware now i don't want to
spoil it by showing the clip in case
there are people that haven't seen
scream but if i did show the clip it
would be this
corn syrup
same stuff they use for pigs blood and
carrie so it's important to note that
the first three child's play movies
weren't like that they were just like
regular movies and now all of a sudden
after stream chucky has become very
self-aware in fact if it was a movie it
would take three or four sequels just to
do it justice and there are all of these
horror movie references such as chucky's
head spinning around 180 degrees like
the scene in the exorcist the character
damien blaylock being a combination of
two characters names from the omen
chucky telling tiff to turn to page 217
in the voodoo for dummies book which is
the same as the haunted room number in
stephen king's novel the shining jade
asking david this question
david you remember when you were seeing
brad parker which seems to be a
combination of brad doreth who plays
chucky and clive barker who created
hellraiser hellraiser is also referenced
after chucky and tiffany take out jade's
uncle chief kincaid by launching these
nails into his face using the van's
airbag why does that look so familiar
that would be because he now resembles
pinhead the iconic character in the
hellraiser movies hellraiser came out a
year before charles lee ray originally
died so it might have been one of the
last movies he ever saw in fact if we
take a closer look at this article about
his death the newspaper reporter
includes an interview with mike norris
the police officer from child's play he
describes the scene as being like
something out of a horror movie there
are some other non-horror references
like tiffany spider being named
charlotte and officer norton referring
to jesse as boogie nights one of the
mysteries of the franchise so far
regards the haitian deity dumbella who
chuck he calls upon to give him the
power to transfer souls we've heard this
dembele chat many times before but this
time we see it in writing inside of
tiffany's voodoo for dummies manual that
means that an english speaker such as
myself can properly translate it for the
first time
the dam bella chant is a french
incantation meaning to the almighty
dambella give me the power i beg of you
to the mercy of my soul to the point of
my death hear me out from my condemned
voice dembele is a haitian entity and if
you're unaware in haiti the official
language is french so that's why the
incantation has to be in french there's
actually a recurring theme of french
phrases being used in the movie when
damian is cringefully trying to seduce
tiffany at the beginning he tells her
about the french saying le petite mortei
the little death and invites her onto
the bed to quote unquote die a little
she asks him if he's ready for a menage
a tuan which is french for threesome
which is also a clue that chucky is
actually alive but damien doesn't quite
get it what's that finally when tiffany
confronts the thieving couple at the
love motel she throws a bottle of
champagne called gudurons or taste of
ross which is the capital of the
champagne and wine growing region in
france now if you would please draw your
attention to the boobs you'll notice
that tiffany has a tattoo with chucky's
name on it and the heart is getting
stabbed by this little dagger she
actually transfers this tattoo to her
doll body after her soul is transferred
during the scene where she dyes her hair
and gives the doll a makeover to look
more like her i don't know what the
point of going through all that was
because she's planning on transferring
back into a human body like within the
next 24 hours seems like a lot of wasted
effort but i think the tattoo shows that
losing chucky in the 1980s broke her
heart but i also find it interesting
because in the first movie that's how
you defeat chucky nora shoots him
through the heart because his organs
have turned human however bride gives
new meaning to rules from the first
movie where john bishop told them that
they had to destroy the heart maybe he
didn't mean that they had to shoot
chucky in the heart because that
obviously only puts him down temporarily
maybe he meant that they needed to
destroy this amulet the heart of
dambella i don't quite get why they feel
the need to retrieve the amulet though
because chucky never attempts to get it
in the first three child's play movies
and there is a later movie where he
takes over a human body without the
amulet so
i don't know i don't have an answer on
this one but on the way to retrieve it
chucky and tiffany cause mayhem all
around them taking out several police
officers and other bystanders causing
their chauffeurs the young couple jesse
and jade to look very guilty as death
follows them everywhere that they go as
they drive through the night we hear one
other song that i want to talk about see
you in hell by monster magnet this song
contains the following lyrics what time
and snow couldn't bear years of
forgotten guilt that little body's
calling rising up from under a jersey
landfill well it isn't a landfill but
they're traveling to new jersey where
the body of charles lee ray would rise
up from underground when his skeleton is
exhumed to double check that he's really
dead because chucky's been leaving
charles leroy fingerprints behind at all
the crime scenes there's also the title
of the song to consider see you in hell
last episode i talked about how chucky
falling into the pit in the devil's lair
dark ride symbolized him descending down
into hell so the title foreshadows this
parting line in bride
goodbye darling
i'll see you in hell
chucky is able to finish tiffany off
though so it ends up being jesse whose
shovel eats him into his own casket
where he starts freaking out
[Music]
what's the matter chucky you act like
you've never seen a dead body before the
very last thing in this movie is the
explosive birth of chucky's offspring
which leads us into the next chucky
movie seed of chucky i'm not thrilled
about covering that one but if i want to
get to curse i'm gonna have to get
through it so check out that video on
the left and remember to subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell and select all
notifications and i will see you in the
next one assuming we both survive